the conspiracy theories are pop in these
days we did a video last week where
people seem to have claimed that area 51
that aliens are there we showed the
video actually we'll link to it right
over here you want to check that one out
but now video has come out of Bigfoot
that's right let's go to the videotape
alright there's no audio to this thing
guys so we can talk through this we're
seeing that it looks like there's some
Buffalo or something in the foreground
but in the background do you see what
there seems to be some sort of a train
look what nope that's a big there's a
big guy with a limp that could that be
Alonso because there are no big guys
with limbs alright I mean people are
saying that that is evidence of Bigfoot
I don't know why twin these video hits
why don't we never get a closer shot why
does no one ever zoom in why is it
always so grainy and blurry and blah
blah blah but I like conspiracy theories
I think it's fun to think about so my
first question is is there a conspiracy
theory that you particularly buy into
before we get to Bigfoot well because it
has an explanation so that's that's the
weirdness of it or all of its a
conspiracy it's a similar to the Bigfoot
the tupa copper does exist but it's just
it's not a mythical creature it's this
rare weird jackal dog type of creature
which is fine there's not many of them
and people see them they'd see this
weird running thing with longer hind
legs it doesn't mean it you have to
freak out about it right so it's not
like for the nuclear waste the dog that
went in then ya know maybe it breaks
into your yard needs your chickens if
you have a farm that's what wild animals
do right so the freaked out about is
what's odd but it exists so would have
to go crazy about not this why are we
still talking about the Bigfoot like
everybody involved in the original
Bigfoot footage say oh we were kidding
yeah I mean like the 1967 footage that
everybody keeps going back to his sort
of the original the guy in the Bigfoot
suit came out about it and like admitted
that he was the guy in the Bigfoot so I
guess it's just people just love this
kind of stuff they loved the idea of a
loch ness monster the idea of the alien
thing you know a conspiracy theory that
you know the JFK assassination I've
watched a gajillion things like I'm not
so sold on what the government has told
us so I I like all of that stuff
Harry and the Hendersons why are they
why did they remade that that was my
last question but I'm moving it up here
fine film John lick wasn't in a TV show
so you have no answer no no none yes
clearly I'm part of the the Bigfoot
conspiracy because I don't know why they
haven't made a hairy man do you guys
think in an age where everything can be
manipulated in Photoshop digitally
altered and all that would there be
anything short of you seeing Bigfoot and
him sitting down right here would there
be any video proof that would be enough
for you to go oh yeah he exists there'd
have to be some video proof but I mean
it needs to be closed and clear again
yes you're saying it first there's
nothing it's it's it's just as grainy as
original as you said when I knew sixties
when I was it 2015 and we still have the
grainy evidence I get it just like
camera that's taken outside is it the
same Bigfoot is it just like Bigfoot's
grandson what do we think how many are
there why are they able you've seen one
at a time makes you wonder right is he
the last I mean there was some
explanations and I said what of a
creature is that big and would be that
close to a safe Amanda Bigfoot suit he's
that close to those wild roaming Buffalo
was the buffalo or bison byeson bum and
then that's dangerous that to be so
close yeah but by the way people get
close to be watch grizzly man
yeah final thought on this what do you
guys make of the people that devote
their lives to this stuff because
there's so many of them and look we're
on YouTube YouTube is the home of
conspiracy theorists and all this stuff
so these people that really spend you
know I watch ancient aliens always have
that spend their lives trying to answer
the unanswerable what do you make them
they've clearly figured out a way to
monetize this sort of thing you know
like whoever's producing that hunting
Bigfoot or that reality how is that they
make fun of on the soup every week yeah
you know someone's someone's cashing
those checks so it's it's it's no Dumber
way to make a living real quick so I
think it's I think the show is called
Finding Bigfoot at my old Sirius XM show
I think her name is ranae Holland if I'm
not mistaken was on the show and she
she's the real skeptic of the bunch of
the Bigfoot hunters
was I can why would I believe in this
freakin thing but she's doing it you
know it's a job and she likes her cheese
are in totally great lady but even some
of these people that are involved in it
you know it's also fun to watch it I
love this story we were doing now
because it's fun it's fun I've watched
some of the Bigfoot story shows but at
least they have to try it's the ones
that don't even try anymore than bother
me or like come on do ya at least try
entertain me yeah and that's exactly by
the way why we do these stories because
we can't always talk about politics and
the government trying to get you you
gotta watch out for chupacabra Loch Ness
monster Bigfoot the aliens what else is
there anything goes naturally ghosts
anyway what do you think do you believe
in conspiracies which one is your
conspiracy of choice let us know in the
comments right now below don't forget to
subscribe